un mot sur chaque ligne abc et tu fais
une phrase avec ça peut être abaissée ou
ac ou et maintenant tous les dans tous
les cas faut que tu fasses eux mehdi
frère de romane maître d'école par la
force des choses depuis plus de deux
semaines le confinement à bouleverser la
vie quotidienne de plusieurs parents en
classe de cm1 à paris romane et donc
encadrée par son papa qui veille au
suivi des devoirs
beaucoup de nouveautés à prendre un rôle
qui n'est normalement pas le nôtre
enseignants c'est un vrai métier
donc c'est surtout du soutien scolaire
puisque de plus que dans l'enseignement
et l'important je pense de ce faire un
programme de définir un programme avec
des réveils heure fixe pour garder un
rythme et évidemment on n'a pas la même
plage horaire que que les journées
d'école mais ces deux volets de
s'organiser toute la journée avec un
programme bien défini grammaire lecture
histoire-géo français ou encore théâtre
le programme est aussi riche que sur les
bancs de l'école
un réveil un peu plus tard qu'à
l'accoutumée trois heures d'enseignement
dans la journée la plus grande
difficulté pour l'enfant s'adapter à un
environnement qui n'est pas celui qu une
salle de classe
nancy peut pas se montrer des concepts
déconcentrer par quoi il m'apparaît tout
ce qu'on a autour de nous puisqu'on
connais beaucoup mieux la salle que
notre classe les parents les poneys
mieux que le professeur alors c'est un
peu plus rigoler et ont tous parlé à
watts il joue comme un imprimé
alors ils savent quand même s'expliquer
cédé à 10 mais le professeur les
explique annie les professeurs maîtres
ou encore maîtresse d'école communique
chaque jour avec les parents un
programme est envoyé à suivre à la
lettre
maître mot de ce confinement continuité
scolaire tant qu'on est on soutient ce
sont des thèmes qui sont acquis ou en
phase d'acquisition pour l'enfant c'est
c'est relativement simple et les
techniques d'enseignement ne sont plus
les mêmes jeux complets comme sur les
mathématiques c'est vraiment une
approche complètement différente si ça
devait de venait à durer et que nous
avons à travailler des thèmes que
l'enfant ne connaît pas un mot n'a
jamais entendu parler là ce serait de
l'enseignement et je pense pas que ce
serait aussi simple autre difficulté à
partir de samedi la zone c dont paris
fait partie est concerné par les
vacances de pâques pour une durée de
deux semaines
et jean michel blanquer air ministre de
l'éducation a évoqué une aide possible
assuré par des professeurs volontaires
mais seulement pour des élèves qui en
aurait vraiment besoin ciblé auparavant
par le ministre